well let's let's let's talk about la
resistance we have this story from the
post millennial trump's new media
platform and rumble have distribution
deal there is a lot of good to discuss
here there's also a decent amount of bad
and concern and the notable thing here
is they say howard lutnik the ceo of
rumble's parent company cantor
fitzgerald stated on monday that they
have worked out a distribution deal with
donald trump's planned truth social
media platforms i want to say right now
when they say that the ceo of rumble's
parent company is cantor fitzgerald that
means rumble is now a subsidiary of
institutional wall street investment
firms that are one of 24 uh investment
firms that can do direct dealings with
the federal reserve
so this does not sound to me like an
independent free safe place to run your
business it sounds just like they're
building the b side to big tech however
that being said you were saying earlier
this lutnik guy was like a big trump
supporter yes the the ceo of kenner
fitzgerald is um i i totally get your
point um but there's good news here
that's why i bring it up there is good
news i mean we do need alternatives and
i think a plurality of voices is
the way to go um but yeah i share your
concern that if it's just owned by
another wall street company who is going
to have to follow sec regulations and
sec regulations under this
administration could be
unless uh 75 of the board of all of your
subsidiaries are made up of people who
we agree with their political persuasion
then you can't get your
uh uh
you know you can't trade on you can't
trade on the big board there's a
possibility here that this is a massive
concerted effort among powerful
interests to counter the woke
establishment big tech
because rumble getting this access and
getting this investment getting this
power could be a good thing if you
believe in the stuff i think the bigger
risk is you know ian mentioned this as
soon as they opened as soon as they go
public with the they did a spec a
special purpose acquisition company
rumble opens the door
to vanguard was it state street
blackrock buying up percentage of the
company and then putting pressure on
them and then they're basically just
google again so it's almost like there's
a fear of a controlled opposition if the
company remain private we have more
reason to believe that they'll actually
stick to their principles and not censor
and ban people but let's read a little
bit of the news here first and then
we'll get into the the tech stuff truth
and the 45th president are going to use
rumble's infrastructure their technology
their cloud distribution capability so
they are going to be a service provider
a tech provider to the president's truth
social lutnik told interviewer john
bachman on his john bachman now show for
something they got joe rogan here for
some reason
rumble a video based pro feast pro free
speech platform works in a similar
manner to other streaming services and
full disclosure we here at tim cast we
use rumble infrastructure and we are
more confident we won't get banned there
but that being said we'll speak honestly
lutnik continued during the interview
what this is is people with political
ideology being asked to leave youtube
comedians are now coming over gamers are
coming over it's a broad group of people
who don't want to be censored they want
to be able to speak their minds speak
their truths and speak their opinions so
i think rumble which is neutral down the
middle i think it's going to get a huge
following of people who just want to
speak their minds lutnik further
iterated that rumble after the the deal
struck with the struck with his company
will now have the money to now go do
whatever they want to do i mean that's
that's potentially good news right
right off the bat this means that all
the people who are worried about not
having a way to compete with youtube's
infrastructure can now go somewhere else
and there's going to be revenue there
what rumble needs to do right now is
they need to use as much money as they
can to create a comparable partner
program that youtube has because the
number one thing that keeps people from
leaving this platform is audience size
but more importantly for newer creators
and new talent it's the fact that
youtube is subsidized by google alphabet
whatever so you
youtube costs google money
but they subsidize it so that people
stay on this platform
if rumble can do the same thing and i
also think they do got to clean up their
interface and you know their website
needs a yeah it's a little help a little
messy
then people are going to be like look if
i'm going to start a channel somewhere
why go on youtube someone is making a
new channel is going to speak out and
speak up against all this you know this
bs going on around the world they're
going to say if i go on youtube i'll get
a strike right like elijah schaefer and
sydney watson friends for instance on
you are here they've gotten how many
strikes already like takedowns like a
couple yeah already and the show's new
so there's gonna be a lot of people
being like i just do it on rumble i
don't have you know people without big
followings without a ton of followers
will just be like i'll start a rumble
channel and then at the very least i can
make money there the exact same way i
could make it on youtube
well it's funny that the same article i
assume this is from today or the last
couple days this article axios uh has a
totally different spin where i think the
headline is i should pull it up the
headline is something like the chamber
the right wing echo chamber and it's
funny it's it's first of all the to
think that like the left isn't just one
echo chamber right like every single
publication newspaper tv outlet is
literally just saying the exact same
thing as the dnc um and it's insulting
to call it an echo chamber because it's
not it's a platform
but it's just it's axios spin we have
the article right here this is there it
is it's how the media lies right
right wing builds its own echo chamber
is an opinion and it's also incorrect
it's a false framing but for them to put
this on a news article it shows you the
the why we need alternative platforms in
a way to kind of this it's not an echo
chamber
just because different right-wing
websites exist doesn't mean people don't
read other news
an echo chamber would be a cultural
phenomenon where people are like i'm not
going to watch any other news but we
know from the data conservatives get
about a third of their news from
mainstream liberal or leftist sources
whereas liberals get five percent so
what we're actually seeing here the news
is right-wing media emerges and it's not
even right-wing it's independent
moderate libertarian and conservative
you know it's an echo chamber the
youtube front page you go on that and
it's the same voices the same political
opinions regurgitate and regurgitate it
to you in in so many different uh
formats i'm skeptical news whenever
sorry whenever you swipe to the left and
you get to the news thing look at apple
look at the top stories on apple news
echo chamber so i'm sorry same talking
points same headlines same kind of
narrative nothing deviating from of
course the larger agenda that's set
against the american people but you know
i'm skeptical of rumble but it's going
to be very interesting to see how
they're going to kind of traverse this
online landscape where they're going to
go how they're going to be different or
if they're just going to be sellouts i'm
skeptical because of things like the esg
the environmental social justice and
government's social credit score that a
lot of top companies have to be
compliant with and the more essentially
woke you are the more you sell out to
the agenda and narrative the better
score you have the more investment money
you have the more economic opportunities
you have the better evaluations you have
so this is a key indicator of of how
it's going to be playing out for many
large corporations so to see rumble in
this system if it's going to be played
by it if it's going to be destroyed by
it i i think it's it's worth starting a
conversation about because it's going to
be very interesting to see if this is
just going to be another sellout major
big tech company that that has a bunch
of people at the top who want to make a
bunch of money
or if it's going to be something that
actually challenges the status quo
challenges the current infrastructure
that people have to fight with that
destroys free speech in the first
amendment
i i think it's like
this challenged me the more the stronger
you per the push the more powerful i
become yes challenge me get bigger get
stronger and then i'll buy you well they
have the one ring they're trying to
defeat sauron with another one ring
they're like i can do it i can withstand
the pressure of being a bit having a
billion dollar centralized social
network with proprietor no one can
withstand that man they're coming with
billions and billions of secs coming and
the government's coming like it's not
chris's company anymore rumble's gone
it's not but i still think this is a big
net positive as much as i don't think
it's a permanent solution they mentioned
at the post-millennial that trump's
anti-big tech social media startup
raised one billion dollars from
investors over the weekend to fund the
digital venture quote one billion
dollars sends an important message to
big tech that censorship and political
discrimination must end america is ready
for truth social a platform that will
not discriminate on the basis of
political ideology trump stated this
will be this will be interesting because
look
i signed up for a rumble uh i'm sorry
not rumble um parlor
we are on rumble but i was i signed up
for parlor like okay okay this is like
the 80th time they've been like this is
the alternative and then trump now i
guess he's using the mastodon code to
launch his own version yeah and they've
acknowledged that as of yesterday oh
okay well at any rate this is one i will
actually immediately sign up for i'll be
like okay you know i'll use this because
it's donald trump it's it's there's
there's power behind it and there's
going to be a big push from everybody
who wants to follow donald trump to be
on that platform that makes it viable
one of the things that makes it really
difficult for all these other
alternative platforms is are there
people there to talk to yeah youtube's
got it twitter's got it facebook has it
but no one really cares about facebook
for the most part now these alternatives
they don't really have it that much even
rumble does not really have it so what
they did was they got you know they paid
for people like like uh siraj has a show
there right and glenn greenwald and a
few other people were paid by rumble to
do you know programming on their
platform because they need people
otherwise why would you go there
all of this stacking up
i actually think we might be seeing what
i've long been asking for so i don't
want to rain on the parade you know when
it now that we're seeing this deal and
we're seeing this investment in this
infrastructure it looks like a lot of
free speech voices or at the very least
people who are mad about being censored
are being like if we don't do something
against big tech we will lose and i've
been saying that over and over again
they think they can go in and say
section 230 reform and i'm like yo
you're sitting on fat stacks why don't
you just be like okay here's 10 million
dollars to fund this the initial
infrastructure get this going well now
there's a billion dollars and it was
raised by guests by investors buying
through the spec so all in all i think
it's pretty good news but of course but
of course well and we're going to get to
the important part here did you think my
friends it would be that easy from cnbc
trump's back under investigation by
federal regulators including the sec the
sec and finra probes were disclosed by a
filing by digital world acquisition corp
the special purpose acquisition company
on track to merge with trump media and
technology group they're already
fighting back the government is coming
after trump and a social media platform
because i think it actually is a threat
to their established narrative bs
it's going to be it's going to be
interesting because trump kind of plays
like he's a part of the establishment
and then kind of counters the
establishment um i obviously don't have
a lot of hope in him personally myself
after his latest moves especially with
some of the interviews that he's been
given on fox news recently uh shilling
for of course uh big pharma that's my
kind of perspective that's my
understanding of it so to see the
government kind of hit him i think it's
more personal than it is anything else
and i think there's a bigger fight here
and we have to acknowledge that fight is
happening but i still see it as one wing
of the same bird kind of slapping each
other uh at the end of the day um from
my own perspective i think if you are
the social media platforms uh
look at what zuckerberg did in the 2020
election through facebook
um and and and how he i mean molly
hemingway's book on that is just
absolutely brilliant um
her book rigged and and how zuckerberg
spent his way into
flipping the election in key states for
for the democrats um they're not going
to give up that power pretty easily so
i'm not surprised that that the fec is
going after this because on the sec is
going after it because they don't want
to lose their power and the biden
administration i mean this is they use
government
uh authoritatively whenever they get the
chance i mean that's the lesson they
learned from obama also heck today also
merrick garland announced he's his uh
he's suing the state of texas again
because are they redistricting because
they don't want the districts drawn that
way because they don't want it drawn
that way because they want to turn texas
blue so what is their lawsuit based on
based on the fact that we don't like
texas and what did bill barr do
nothing yeah nothing republic you know
look republicans and democrats they're
both establishment the reason the
republicans haven't been doing anything
for years is because they're just
stopping the populist movement and the
working class from actually getting
anything done and the democrats because
they have a bunch of
ignorant young people just marching
blindly behind them they're able to you
know crack the whip and get away with it
because of the tribal nature of what
they're what they're what they're doing
but i mean there should be alarm bells
to anybody trump starts a media company
and also the sec is investigating dude
i'm calling bs on that come on we saw
what happened with obama and the tea
party and the irs
using the power of the government to
harass and coerce and go after anyone
who opposes you
yep this is just them vying for power
and when they have power they of course
conceal it for themselves use it for
their own personal benefit and when you
see it from that perspective these
larger kind of spats and fights kind of
do make sense because it's you know the
left wing versus the right wing um so we
we have seen that this abused so much um
and i remember even doing a news story
about 10 years ago talking about how
social media could decide elections
there was numerous studies being done
that came to the conclusion saying if
you just tweaked the algorithm a little
bit if you just tweak what people see
and don't see you could literally change
the future of this country this was
something that we were talking about 10
years ago i think this has become
something that's not just a possibility
i think it's a reality and i think we
need to acknowledge what you mentioned
is that big tech social media does
affect elections does affect who gets
voted in and of course they have a clear
side with anyone who of course does
their bidding who of course anyone who
works for them and is willing to help
them out at the end of the day and they
have cure a pure
financial interest right i mean look at
some of the players in this
not social media but it's media michael
bloomberg one of the top 10 what richest
people in the nation uh the two guys
from google alphabet uh
top five richest people in uh the nation
zuckerberg top five richest people in
the uh
who goes
and then he's the man who helped start
one of the major super pacs that that of
course spread the first kind of term of
of russian collusion so so there's
they're integrated in so many different
ways eric schmidt said he that he uh
supports hillary clinton he backed her
in so many different ways but he
there's so many other things happening
behind the scenes that aren't even
public that we don't even know about
them that truly do highlight the bigger
power plays at hand here behind the
scenes and obviously right now the power
establishment that's in charge is the
corporate neoliberal uh fascistic
establishment that is parading itself as
a social justice warrior woke ideology
when in reality they're they are
technocrats and that's exactly what i
would call them absolutely total
authoritarians because they also support
black lives matter if you ask them they
they were all behind the russia
collusion they probably all support
vaccine mandates and they're all worth
60. they only support black lives matter
when it supports their divide and
conquer agenda when at the same time
they pass initiatives that largely
discriminate against them just like
these larger vax mandates predominantly
discriminate against black people and
now not only their opportunity to go to
places inside but now their opportunity
to even find a job where new york city
predominantly the majority of people who
haven't taken the vaccine are black now
they can't get a job so can't go to the
library you can't go to the library
they took away all their economic
opportunities but these are the same
people cheerleading we support black
lives matter no matter what no you don't
you support your agenda and they use the
power of the government to crush their
opposition exactly but we got something
interesting here devin nunes is retiring
oh yeah so he's going to be joining the
trump media firm
and i can't say i'm surprised that the
feds are going after trump's media firm
but he wrote a letter he basically said
um
nuna said in a letter to his
constituents that he'll be leaving at
the end of 2021 prior to the 2022
midterms recently i was presented with
an opportunity to fight for the most
important issues i believe in i'm
writing to let you know i've decided to
pursue this opportunity and therefore i
will be leaving the house of
representatives at the end of 2021 rest
assured i have not by any means given up
our collective fight i'll just be
pursuing it through other means
so uh nunes announced his resignation
the trump and media technology group
released a statement saying nunes would
be the company's chief executive officer
i would love to see uh to have devin on
the show to discuss this mr nunes
congressman and talk about what's going
on with this because i certainly believe
devin nunes is a fighter so i've been
concerned about what's been happening
with like the acquisition of of locals
and stuff
seeing this i do think there's another
risk of big tech
just because they say they're going to
protect us and protect our rights and
allow free speech doesn't mean that in
five years time they actually will it'll
be other people with other interests
another agenda in power and the ability
to censor you so i'm all about
decentralizing this stuff and then
hooking into the machine what these
people have been doing have been
building a centralized system just to
give themselves power so it's it's one
thing to be like
i believe everyone should have access to
communication and it's another thing to
see two warring factions arguing over
who which which one of them gets to have
control over the means of communication
right yeah i think the interesting thing
about nuna's retiring i just wanted to
confirm that he is from california he is
from california
um which means the governor will
renounce his replacement um pelosi does
not have a very big majority
he would not risk the larger
right-of-center agenda if he thought
anything was in risk so i think devin
nunes knows nothing's going to happen
next year like my being there or
replacing me with a democrat is going to
mean absolutely nothing to the agenda
what does that mean does that mean the
republicans are aren't going to win that
no that means that the the house will be
in total stalled next year they're not
going to get anything through the senate
that they'll just be on vacation that's
my hunch i don't think he would leave oh
right right if he was like we have the
midterm elections yeah we have these
really big bills that are coming up i
gotta be there because we only have a
three-vote leader right right right he's
like he's right doesn't make a
difference he's right i mean it's tribal
right now the democrats have the house
and it's not going to be until what
january 3rd 2023 before which even if
the right way red wave happens and think
of how sad that is in terms of just
civics that we are already dismissing
all of next year nothing will happen in
dc
what a colossal waste of space and time
and money all these people are going to
be flying here and they're going to be
having meetings
people like you you describe the perfect
definition of government right there
that was it say that sentence
in and they're going to have these
hearings but no it's just how how how
embarrassing is it like it's all just a
joke it's just a it always was i know
it always has been and it always was and
i and i take a stagnant government that
keeps fighting itself and doesn't
accomplish anything and doesn't pass new
rules and laws is the best government
and inactive government is the best
government people could ask for because
it doesn't get involved in anyone's
business i i i disagree luke at this
point um a government that begins
repealing laws and adding sunset clauses
to uh you know existing laws is the kind
of government we need if the republicans
had a backbone and actually did some of
that i would agree with you but they
don't they usually comply and they just
want to add new
bureaucracies new jurisdictions and new
regulations that gives them power and
gives them authority
i wish there was a political system or a
political party that represented
repealing a lot of the bureaucracy
repealing a lot of the dumb regulations
that hurt small businesses that prevent
people from competing with amazon and
walmart and costco and whoever it may be
that's the department of commerce yeah
seventeen thousand people work there
look at what a good job they're doing
yeah right yeah so i i wish there was
the the slow kind of recalling of all
this nonsense i wish we just had one
rule we talked about this on the show a
number of times just makes make a sunset
clause on all laws on all rules on all
regulations just let them expire uh
please because there's so much bull crap
that the average american has to deal
with every single day when it comes to a
mafioso middleman
uh government thug interfering in their
livelihoods it's it's impossible to make
ends meet for a lot i wish the founding
fathers
added an additional amendment that you
know the constitution can be amended in
these ways however statutory laws passed
by congress will all have a natural
sunset period and the reason for that is
and they could have they could have done
like a natural sunset of 20 years or
something to recognize
rules change by generation and new
generations coming in will need to
assess the rules of the previous
generation determine if they're still
you know applicable to what's what our
society is like today and i think then
you have the constitution which is
mostly immutable it's very difficult to
change but can be amended if everyone
comes together and and mostly agrees and
then when it comes to statutory law
these things got to get reviewed because
right now
if they put up i would say this in about
10 years i i'm willing to bet
gun control is going to be in the gutter
2a advocates are winning they're winning
like crazy and that means the younger
generation the leftists who are pro-gun
and the right populist and the
independents and libertarians are
winning on this front
absolutely
they would be like oh we're gonna review
this nfa thing throw it in the gutter
that being said they can go in and then
be like hey we're all gonna vote to
throw this nfa thing in the gutter so
that's
in my opinion a good thing but i think
with sunset clauses it makes it happen a
little bit faster where whereas you
might need a certain amount of votes to
get past a filibuster or get it through
a veto with a sunset if they don't vote
to uphold it it's just gone whereas
right now if they say you know we're
gonna pass the the repealing the nfa act
and then biden's just like vetoed get
out of here and then they're like we
can't get the two-thirds majority to you
know to get the to over override the
veto so you can't do it
with the sunset they just be like
ain't nobody voting for it so we got a
simple majority it's out that'd be
fantastic thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you